you're a doctor yeah well doctor degree
in physical therapy what made you choose
that profession I wanted to not ever
work in like a cubicle or anything like
that my mom never liked her job I would
hear her hating her job all the time she
like I just sit in this cubicle I hate
it and I was like all right I don't want
to do that so then I wanted to work with
kids so I became a pediatric physical
therapist cuz you work with adults and
then they they're not grateful at all
but when you work with kids especially
disabled kids I mean dude they're all in
wheelchairs they have cereal paly and
this and that and just to get them to
like stand up or take a step it's like a
Monumental task and I'm like this feels
better than massaging someone's Pinky
and then them you know calling me a
piece of cuz I messed one
thing up you know yeah